have you ever had to tell someone that
they are best suited to a subservient /
blue-collar lifestyle because they don't
have any semblance of brilliance okay
well I want to take issue with the
formulation of that question although I
think it's a perfectly reasonable
question that's Jan Swan don't be
thinking that a blue-collar lifestyle is
necessarily subservient I mean first of
all you can be a trades person and
that's a really good career choice as
far as I'm concerned it's very very
valuable
I mean you know good plumbers are rare
and good carpenters are rare and good
bricklayers are rare and they're so
useful I mean I do a lot of renovation
work I've done an awful lot of
renovation work on all the places I've
lived in and I've learned to do a fair a
bit of construction and automotive
bodywork and all those sorts of things
and I really like doing it and you know
there's their blue-collar life is not
necessarily subservient at all because
you can be master of your trades domain
and be unbelievably economically useful
and productive and creative and
independent and autonomous and so
there's there's nothing necessarily
subservient about that now you know if
you're thinking more about about let's
say life at the low end of a restaurant
but even there if you're a conscientious
person and you're careful in you and
you're awake and you treat the people
around you well and you do your job
properly there's also room for
advancement in the private sphere
there's no reason to assume whatsoever
that merely because you don't have the
intellectual horsepower to work well in
the ABS in that in the domain of rapidly
shifting abstractions that your life has
to be of secondary quality or or or
opportunity I don't see that at all and
and there's endless opportunity in the
trades and I can in Toronto for example
there's a chronic shortage of trades
people and there's always a shortage of
qualified people for every occupation so
if I have to tell someone that they're
best suited to a blue-collar lifestyle I
wouldn't feel bad about it I might save
them a look you know um you you know
let's assume you talk to someone who has
an IQ of 100 which is the IQ of the
average high school graduate you might
say well look you know let's you're
super conscientious a career in
something like law is probably not your
best bet because you're going to be
competing with
people who have IQs that are like 30
points higher than yours or 25 points
higher than yours and if you really work
yourself to death you might be able to
main maintain competitiveness in that
domain but you're going to be working at
a powerful disadvantage because the
people that you're competing with for
example are going to be way faster than
you verbally they'll be able to read
faster into reason verbally faster and
and all of that and it might be better
to pick up an ambition that's more in
keeping with the quality of your
temperament and your intelligence to put
it bluntly so that you can be but that
doesn't mean that your success has to be
limited and it also doesn't mean that
I'm invading intelligence to to the
platform of the ultimate moral ideal
because the relationship between
intelligence and moral ideal is zero
there's no relationship between them at
all intelligence is a is a capacity
let's say that can be put to ill use
just as well as to good use and there's
nothing intrinsically better about smart
people they might be more useful for
certain things if they're oriented
towards the good but there's absolutely
there's no shortage of opportunity in
the working class end of the end of the
world and I can certainly understand
often why people might prefer that too
to the endless miasma you might say
chaotic miasma of complex abstract jobs
one of the problems with those sorts of
jobs is that you've never done it never
finished
there's always more work than you can
possibly do